all right troopers we're coming in hot
on the LZ and we're gonna take
objectives until kylo Ren throws a
tantrum and kills all of you or you win
whichever comes first
another victory for the first-order
here's how not to suck at power fun to
use classes let's start by getting some
housekeeping out of the way yes loot
crate's Arcana annoying and yes crafting
parts come in slow which is why we're
gonna take you to the four classes of
Battlefront two and show you how they
operate and where you should consider
investing your valuable time and
resources battlefront 2 is more of a
battlefield game than the last version
which was some kind of Mario Kart coin
picking up vs this time around you are
massively more rewarded for staying with
your squad and playing actual objectives
for this piece let's focus on the
combined arms mode galactic assault
number 1 the officer you can think of
the officer as a frontline problem
solver with hard-hitting pistols and an
arsenal of nifty little tricks when it
comes to blasters there's no contest get
you the blerg 1120 burst pistol with
explosive plasma mod and improved burst
mod to squirt off for explosive rounds
with each trigger pull dumb name high
rate of murder in close quarters next
get rid of that useless blaster turret
it's not very good and usually by the
time you set it down the frontline has
moved on heavy class is a much better
one that we'll get into in a bit instead
invest in the support trifecta craft the
defuser that temporarily disables all
incoming grenade spam the squad shield
that can protect objectives while
they're being armed in disruption that
overheats all enemy weapons in range one
of the bigger issues in the tight
corridors of some maps such as Death
Star 2 and Naboo is grenade spam and
choke points so mainly use the officer
and these cards to break through with
your team by temporarily disabling most
of the enemy teams advantages bottom
line is if your squad is in front of you
then you're doing it right next up is
the heavy class out of the box the
heavies and oddly situational soldier
that is extremely powerful with the
right ability at the right range the
downside of this class is slow mobility
that makes them phone
explosives but break when it comes to
their heavy repeaters I hate to say this
but the last one in the roster the TL 50
is the most versatile with a high rate
of fire and the ability to alt fire
concussion grenades you can get lucky
and find it in a crate or grind out
those 500 kills since that's a huge
investment maybe go to the DC 15 le
first it has a similar rate of fire and
you can craft reduced recoil and
exploding shots for similar effect the
biggest trick to mastering heavy is
knowing when to cancel your abilities in
order to move away from certain doom
someone up in your face pop the combat
shield and take them down doing this you
can even win 1v2 situations do not try
this beyond medium-range enemy team far
away but in the open pops entry and mow
them down far away but behind cover use
the explosive sentry star card and kill
around corners or at least temporarily
shut down lanes while your team moves
forward fun note this also works at
extreme range to kill snipers you can
also create more mobile versions of
heavy by using the barrage star card in
place of sentry and taking the ion
turret for backup because it can target
both infantry and soldiers although if
you go that route you might as well play
as a salt and we'll get to that next
next up is assault this class is made to
maneuver and flank hands-down the best
gun in this class for the fastest play
style is the CR 2 SMG that can be made
even better with reduced recoil mods
it's pretty much the only SMG in the
game although it can be fun to use the e
l16 HFE which acts like a designated
marksman rifle in traditional
battlefield fair warning though this is
also the last rifle of the bunch
requiring 500 kills to attain the
assault class is probably the most
vanilla of the bunch and a great place
to start if you're not familiar with
battlefront there star card selection is
more limited but that's fine because
they're very strong as is they make up
the bulk of frontline soldiers dodging
throwing grenades and taking down
opponents in nimble fashion star cards
that support their playstyle are the
ones that make you tougher to kill such
as bodyguard take less explosive and
toxic damage or the ones that give you
more damage output like improved thermal
detonator acid launcher or just improve
scanned art when used in a group several
assault players can go straight at the
enemy team any one of them can fire a
skinned dart to see who and what's in
front of them while another assault
player pops Vanguard to get sneakier on
the sides
it's usually a suicidal maneuver but
often flips the odds in your squads
favor allowing them to push through if
anything the assault class is great for
racking up battle points and grabbing
heroes to support the team they even
have a start card to let them get more
battle points assault is fast so focus
on objectives throwing finally there's a
specialist
even though dice went through great
lengths to say this game is no
battlefield somehow this class still has
the glaring lens flare from battlefield
and it gives away their position every
time they aim down sights annoying but
not insurmountable noobs play this class
is a long-range murder machine veterans
know how to spot and support their team
with thermal binoculars that literally
let you see the position of the entire
enemy team through walls with some
proper communication you could be the
de-facto field commander the improved
thermal binocular star card lets you
spot without using your keyboard or
using your mouth parts and I'd highly
recommend it the trick to mastering this
class is to use binoculars to spot a
name only bringing up your rifle for a
quick kill shots before immediately
going back to your binoculars this
ensures you're giving away your position
for the smallest period of time there
are a few must-have star cards for this
class stealth ensures you remain off
radar when aiming scramble infiltration
ensures you stay off radar when moving
and the stinger pistol card is deadly up
close where rifles may fail you while
also doing bonus damage to heroes in
summary hang back you don't spend a lot
of time looking through your rifle
sights use abilities to stay off the
enemy radar focus on enemies at
objectives and communicate communicate
communicate alright that should get you
started at the hole not sucking and
Battlefront to thing this game has a
surprising amount of depth and star
cards let you create some pretty
interesting bills we want to hear about
yours
what creative classes have you developed
lately let's talk tactics in the
comments below and if you have something
particularly cool we may feature it in
the next video thanks for watching and
the force with you may be it or however
Yoda says it damn love it
you
[Music]